-Wow.
Family reunion is a hit!
We haven't had this many people
in the house in two years.
-I know. But I'm honestly
a little worried
about all these people
using our bathroom.
Can the septic handle it?
-Don't worry.
We've got AeroToilet.
-Aero what?
-From the makers of AeroBed,
now there's AeroToilet,
the inflatable guest toilet
you can really
go to the bathroom in.
-Huh!
-In seconds, it's fully inflated
and ready to use.
And voilà -- your home office
becomes our new guest bathroom.
-Wow!
That's amazing.
-Go ahead.
Give it a try.
-Oh, boy!
Whoa! Whoa!
Is this supposed
to wobble like this?
-Just adjust the firmness
with that little toggle there.
-Oh.
[ Air hisses ]
-Better?
-Much.
I mean,
I'm using this exactly the way
I'd use a regular
ceramic toilet.
-That's the whole point.
-I mean, I can really do it all.
-And more.
And AeroToilet goes anywhere.
And it's so affordable,
you'll want one
for every corner of your house.
And since there's no plumbing,
there's no place
AeroToilet can't go.
-Okay, that's awesome.
-Not near an outlet?
Just inflate manually
using the convenient mouth tube.
[ Blowing ]
-Ooh, careful not to suck.
-Good thinking.
-Great party, Terry.
And I love the house.
What is it, a three bedroom,
nine bath?
[ Both laugh ]
[ Zipper unzips, urinating ]
-There's even
inflatable toilet paper
and an inflatable magazine,
if you get bored.
-Who is ready
for another hot dog?
-Right after this game.
[ Toilet squeaking ]
-Oh, yes!
-Oh, wow.
Looks like it's getting
pretty full.
-Yeah.
-Now what?
-Well, when it's time
for the guests to leave,
all you do is open
this handy valve and --
-John! Not in here!
There's no plumbing!
-Oh, my God!
It's going everywhere!
-Everybody run!
-We're all gonna die!
[ Screaming ]
-AeroToilet,
from the makers of AeroBed.
Not safe for pool use.
-Occupied.
[ Chuckles ]